oh the climate crisis the climate's not  natural it's not the glaciers  you're causing it how are you causing  that well Jane fond has thought a lot  about that topic and here's her  conclusion if there were no racism  there'd be no climate crisis if there  was no misogyny there'd be no climate  crisis it's a it's part of a mindset  it's the mindset that looks at a woman  and says nice  in other words my ex-husbands cause  climate change  in addition to everything else it's all  about her so great subscribe to the Fox  News YouTube channel to catch our  nightly opens stories that are changing  the world and changing your life from  Tucker Carlson tonight